police are investigating a death just
north of downtown las vegas
thank you for joining us tonight at 11
o'clock i'm sasha loftis
officers say a man was found in an alley
near bonanza and maryland parkway
earlier this evening and they're still
trying to determine whether this was the
result of a crime
madison kimbrough joins us live with the
latest on this developing story tonight
madison yeah sasha this happened around
6 45 this evening and a man said
said to be between his 30s and 40s was
found in this alleyway that you see
right here by these homes and you can
see
he was struck with severe injuries the
victim who is said
to be a white man was found dead on
scene police say they're not a hundred
percent
certain that this is a homicide as his
death may have been caused by
a severe fall appears that he could
potentially
he could be a homeless person he could
live in the area we're still trying to
figure it out
it's a unique scene that we're dealing
with
we've been out here for about an hour
and a half and we're still trying to
make that determination
what caused the injuries
originally police entered a home by the
alleyway to see if the victim was tied
to the residence at
all or if there were any other victims
but as of now there is no relation
currently there are no witnesses at this
time but there were two anonymous calls
made
alerting metro of the body so metro is
asking anyone
for help if they know anything about
this incident to please call crime
stoppers to remain anonymous
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now